now you may know Sean Parker as the
co-founder of Napster the first
president of Facebook and the force
behind Spotify but now the tech
entrepreneur is looking to make his mark
in the world of philanthropy and he is
committing six hundred million dollars
to launch the Parker foundation
Stephanie ruhle sat down with Sean to
find out how he plans to put his money
to work we're focused largely on global
Public Health that specifically malaria
life sciences in particular an emerging
field called cancer immunotherapy which
is leveraging the immune system to fight
cancer it's also the case that in order
to maximize impact I need to work on
problems where because of some novel
insight the problem is essentially
hackable there's some relatively
short-term way of having a large impact
that that may not have been tried so
cancer is an interesting one in the
sense that there's no lack of resources
since Nixon declared the war on cancer
the US government has spent hundreds of
billions of dollars in this fight over
four billion dollars a year just on NCI
funding plus countless billions of
dollars spent by private donors so it's
not a resource issue it's a resource
allocation issue it's a it's a
philosophy of science issue it has to do
with how those resources are utilized I
think there's a lot of large private
foundations that stay away from cancer
because they feel like there's they have
nothing to offer my involvement in the
field of cancer started from a kind of
insight that the immune system could
play a role in both preventing and
fighting cancer and now we have two
fda-approved drugs both of which have
been incredibly successful in treating
melanoma and we're on the road to having
a number of cell based therapies that
utilize your body's own t-cells to fight
cancer is this all philanthropy for you
or as an
are you involved in medical research
technology we try to keep the two as
separate as possible and as I become the
other they could and I mean that the the
idea of venture philanthropy is is
exciting and it's important I think any
investing that we did in the space would
happen through the foundation and not
individually are you so involved or do
you feel like you're filling a void in
terms of philanthropy specifically in
medical research in part because NIH has
lost so much funding so there's no
question that there's been a huge
historical hit to research and
development the u.s. because NIH funding
has not been restored and has not
continued you know at the pace of
inflation over the last decade or so
there's a there's an organization I'm
involved with called act for NIH that's
working specifically on this issue and
there's an in fact a bill in front of
Congress called 21st century cures which
hopefully will restore NIH funding to
its previous levels and those are those
are both really important things but but
I think I think fundamentally cancer
research is extremely well-funded
there's a question about how effectively
are those funds being utilized I think
that's the more important question in
the case of of cancer research that was
market-makers anchors Stephanie ruhle
speaking with Sean Parker about the
launch of his foundation